today on the matt wall show as people
are canceled for tweets and jokes and
opinions we'll consider the major pop
star who admitted publicly to drugging
and robbing men
and yet has not been cancelled for it
what does that tell us about canceled
culture also
five headlines including columbia
university working towards racial
equality and equity by holding
segregated graduation ceremonies and
sharon osborne facing the
repercussions of briefly disagreeing
with the left about something
and also marvel announcing their new gay
captain america
that's historic finally in our daily
cancellation we'll discuss the rampant
cultural appropriation that is taking
place today on st patrick's day
i for one will have none of it all of
that and more today on the matt wall
[Music]
show
so after cardi b took to the grammy
stage in what appeared to be
a costume from a never aired show girls
power rangers crossover film
and writhed about on a large bed while
lip-syncing to her x-rated hit [ __ ]
many people pointed out the obvious
irony here was a major pop star
flopping around on the stage screaming
about her genitals
during prime time on a major network
even as certain dr seuss books looney
tunes characters muppet films and disney
cartoons
have recently been criticized censored
or taken out of publication completely
for their supposedly objectionable
content it would seem that our culture
has a rather confused idea
about what sorts of material might be
damaging to impressionable children
or impressionable adults for that matter
now it might be more accurate to say
that our culture doesn't really care
about protecting kids from damaging
material
and only uses those concerns as a
vehicle to enact sweeping cultural
changes
either way the contrast between wap and
dr
seuss is as instructive as it is
depressing and it's also the kind of
conversation that would cause previous
generations
if they look through a crystal ball and
overheard it to throw themselves off of
cliffs and mass
yet the really profound cancel culture
hypocrisy as it relates to cardi b
can be found not in her music but in
something else
recall that the singer only a few years
ago confessed on camera
to drugging and robbing men in a deleted
instagram video she boasted of having
lured men she didn't say how many but it
would seem that there were numerous
victims
from the strip club where she worked
back to a hotel room where she committed
these felonies against them
now the clip is kind of hard to
understand but uh here it is again
anyway listen
[Music]
because i did it myself
[Music]
that's what i used to do
[Music]
truly a scholar is this woman
and she's trying to prove that she
deserves her success
by telling us that she is guilty of
multiple felonies
but i mean i deserve to be successful
i'm a criminal
that's the logic now when this video
resurfaced in 2019 cardi b addressed it
but never used the phrase i'm sorry
she merely admitted that she's quote not
a perfect person which may be
the only understated thing she's ever
written or said and explained that
whether or not they were poor choices at
the time i did what i had to do to
survive
whether or not they were poor choices
this is a justification not an apology
it's also a lie
in other interviews the rapper has
bragged that she earned upwards of three
thousand dollars a night from stripping
by the age of 21 she claimed she had 20
grand and singles
saved by 22 she was starring on a
reality show love in hip-hop new york
so when exactly was she so poor and
destitute that she had to drug and rob
people to survive
it doesn't appear that cardi b views
drugging and assaulting people as any
kind of serious action requiring
desperation to justify anyway
now even if she did view it that way
she'd be wrong but her own words suggest
otherwise
in a different video while dispensing
some helpful relationship advice
she said that if a man cheats on her
she'll quote take him out
drug him then enlist a quote [ __ ] her
words not mine
to sexually assault him while he's
inebriated this is again this is what
she said let's listen to that
cheat on me i'll be that guy i'm gonna
take him out we're gonna get drunk i'm
gonna get him
all perked up and everything we're gonna
have a good time
get him super twisted then bring a [ __ ]
around
we're gonna have a threesome and when he
wake up he's gonna be like what the [ __ ]
yeah because the [ __ ] was a [ __ ] i
mean like yup
yup we had a threesome with the [ __ ]
yep
yep but training suck it you don't got
another to get even
this woman's iq is i mean it has to be
at least double digits
now it's not clear if she's actually
done this herself or she's simply
recommending it as a course of action
nobody's thought to ask because none of
this has been judged important by our
cultural overlords
now a contestant on the bachelor
attended an old south themed frat party
in 2018
and that past infraction made it around
the same age when cardi b was committing
violent crimes that would land less
privileged people
in prison for three decades has been
judged so severe
that multiple tearful apologies are not
enough to rectify it
we've seen people cancelled for tweets
and jokes and off the cuff comments
and other sins which cause no physical
harm or any other kind of harm to anyone
we've seen people lose their jobs and
their livelihoods for opinions they
expressed or words they said
no matter the context or intent or how
long ago it was
cardi b has survived all of those rounds
of canceling the cancel mob has not just
passed her over or looked the other way
but given her a pass
from all present and future
cancellations
she's afforded this privilege for
obvious reasons for one thing
the primary transgression that will get
you canceled is having white skin it's
no coincidence
that almost every cancelled person you
can name is white
cardi b has not committed that violation
so that's the first thing for another
the leftist cancel mob truly considers
an offensive opinion joke tweet or word
to be far more dangerous and evil than
drugging and robbing people especially
men
it's not as though they're they're
gritting their teeth and merely putting
up with cardi b in spite of these
terrible things that she had boasted of
doing
no it's that they don't care or worse
they love her even more for sticking it
to the patriarchy by means of violent
felonies
in a culture where feelings are king the
worst thing you can do even worse than
violent crime a lot worse
is have unapproved feelings or opinions
or to offend the feelings of someone who
has approved opinions
what all this means is that
well it means a lot but here's one thing
we can at least put to rest
the flimsy rationalization that cancel
culture is really a matter of
accountability
i mean if that's all the mob was doing
holding people accountable
then certainly cardi b would be in line
for a little accountability of her own
she might at a minimum be expected to
reach into the ample profit she's earned
from singing about her body parts
and repay the men she robbed that
wouldn't even come close to full
accountability full accountability would
involve her sitting in a jail cell
until sometime in the 2050s but it would
be something
instead we get nothing we focus on
holding random bachelor contestants
accountable for the frat parties they
attended
and newspaper editors accountable for a
single word they said on one instance an
entirely innocent context two years ago
while criminal sociopaths like cardi b
carry on making their millions
spewing filth into our children's ears
and never having to apologize for
anything
call that what you want but please do
not call that
accountability now let's get to our five
headlines
[Music]
you know a lot of us if we grew up in
the ancient times of say the 90s or any
time before that or even more recently
you may have a lot of priceless memories
that are stored
on technology that is not really
considered technology anymore you got
home movies you have
you know physical pictures and all of
that problem is that um
you know those things are sitting in a
box somewhere in the attic or in the
basement
really bad idea especially put them in
the basement if you have them there and
every day that goes by it's a risk
because they can be destroyed that's why
you need
legacy box legacy box is a way for you
to easily and affordably digitally
preserve your past
the process from start to finish is
really easy you pack and send
all the stuff you want them to digitize
their team digitizes everything by hand
and then they send it back to you so all
you got to do is just put the stuff in a
box and send it up
it's that easy get back perfectly
preserved digital copies on thumb drives
dvd or the cloud ready to watch and
share and enjoy
um for years and decades to come plus
they keep you up to date with regular
email updates throughout the digitizing
process so it's a lot of fun as well
i've done it myself
you should do it i could not recommend
it enough get started preserving your
past today go to legacybox.com walls to
get an incredible 50
off your order today buy today to take
advantage of this exclusive offer
and send in when you're ready go to
legacybox.com walsh and say 50
while supplies last so a tweet here from
abc reporter ben siegel it says um
potus tells george stephanopoulos that
his dog major
did not bite someone and penetrate the
skin
he said 85 of the people there love him
all he does is lick them and wag his
tail
we're in the process of having a
training session so there was there was
reports that the dog had been biting
people
and that they had to um they had to
send the dog to somewhere else send the
dog to the big
doggy house in the sky no i don't think
they did that i think i sent it to
wilmington
um which is almost as bad as being
killed but in any case
now now the the biden is defending the
dog and saying no well 85 percent of
people love them can i just say
85 percent is not a good figure that's
that's not
that raises some questions about the 15
there are a lot of people in the white
house
hundreds 15 of them don't like this dog
no if if there is even one person
um in an indoor environment who doesn't
like a dog then that dog should not be
there
because the indoors are for people not
dogs
dogs really don't belong in the white
house dogs don't belong in any house
dogs belong outside because they are
smelly
beasts that's where they belong
i don't hear any complaints you know i'm
right
and don't tell me well the dogs won't
survive outside well you know
it's if an animal can't survive in
nature
then then natural selection has to take
its course that's all you know
that's it i'm sure we can all agree on
that
there'll be no complaints about what i
just said okay let's go to number one
here from fox news it says columbia
university is planning to hold six
additional graduation ceremonies for
students according to their race and
other aspects of how they identified
the new york city schools website
details graduation ceremonies for
native amer for native asian latinx and
black students taking place for columbia
college
columbia engineering general studies in
barnard's college at the end of april
another dubbed fli graduation is for
first
generation and or low-income communities
and then the school is also hosting a
lavender graduation for the lgbtiaq plus
community
so now they they're defending this by
saying that they're still having
a regular gener graduation for everybody
but then they're gonna have the
segregated ones too
on top of that so that makes it okay
so if you had segregated drinking
fountains but you also had a drinking
fountain
that anyone could use but that would
make it okay you got black and white
drinking fountain
so we go back to that black and white
drinking fountains and then
anyone complains we say no no but
there's also drinking drinking fountain
across the hallway that you can
anyone can use that one
this is this is this is simple this is
segregation this is
actual racial segregation that is being
reinstated
by the left and it does make me wonder
so if you've got the regular graduation
and then
all these other graduations does that
mean that
so what about a a student who's a
student also
gay also um black also
indigenous will they go to like six
different graduations
i guess so this is how we have it it
really is
amazing to witness how we've gone just
full circle right back to jim crow
and we are doing it in the name of
racial tolerance
and equality going right back to
separate but equal
and i hate to use the phrase the the
term because this is so overused and
used so often
by people who've never even read the
book but or any of his books but this
but it really is orwellian there's no
other
real word to describe it the way that
racial equality has now become
synonymous
with the very thing that those who
were fighting for racial equality
historically were trying to get rid of
which would be segregation now in more
racial insanity news the atlantic
surprisingly enough
has an editorial about the blm
indoctrination happening in our schools
and the article is titled what happens
when a slogan becomes curriculum
and it starts by saying last month a
public school district that serves
mostly elementary and middle school
students in evanston illinois
held its third annual black lives matter
at school week of action
using curriculum created in
collaboration with black lives matter
activists and the local teachers union
that introduces children as young as
four and five to some of america's most
complex and controversial subjects for
example
parents of kindergartens and
kindergartners in district 65 were asked
to spend time at home discussing a book
on race that teachers had read aloud to
their children
teachers had already read it out loud at
the school
and now uh parents are being asked to
talk about this book at school
the book is called not my idea a book
about whiteness
it's it's more anti-white brainwashing
um this
this book is being read by the way to
kids all over the country not just in
this one school district
to give you an idea of what's in it i
found a youtube video of a guy
uh reading the book and here's something
that i found that appears
towards the end of um of this book and
it's it's kind of interesting
let's listen to it here it is because
anastasia higginbotham is fun
and and creates little things at the
ends of her books here are some
activities
want to know whose liberation you're
fighting for your own
white supremacy has been lying to kids
for centuries white supremacy is pretend
the truth is much simpler dangerous
not dangerous whiteness is a bad deal
it always was all right here's a
contract
binding you to whiteness you get
stolen land stolen riches special favors
then there's little footnotes says land
riches and favors may be revoked at any
time
for any reason whiteness gets to mess
endlessly with the lives of your friends
neighbors loved ones and all
fellow humans of color for the purpose
of profit
the only price is your soul sign below
dude we can see your pointy tail yeah
who do you think is trying to make this
deal
not an angel you can be white
without signing on to whiteness
okay so whiteness is a bad deal and
that's that's the deal that this again
this
book they're reading two kids goes
without saying but i'll say it again
because i always say things that go
without saying
um that could be really be the name of
the show it goes without saying
so it goes without saying but um
there's there's no universe in which
they're reading a book called a book
about blackness
and it contains a page that says
blackness is a bad deal
no universe you can only do that with
white people right
but what is the what's what's the deal
they say if you if you sign on the
contract and you say i want to be a part
of whiteness i'm a white
i'm a white person whiteness is uh
that's that's what i want
you get stolen land um
money and special favors
sounds like a good deal i mean i think
i'll take it actually
if that's what you're offering me sounds
pretty good
i don't know when i get to cash in i'm
like a sucker i'm paying for the land
that i'm on
i haven't gotten any of this stuff but
i'll take it
see let's let's put aside for a moment
the fact that this is totally nonsense
um and that this is
the idea that this this is what comes
with being white
and by the way if if we are all living
on quote-unquote stolen land which we're
not
but if we are then everybody in the
country is two not just white people
it's that would mean black people also
our state are living on stolen land
if i'm responsible for stealing land
then so is
my black neighbor because we're living
in the same literally on the same street
right
but let's put all that aside from it
what the what they're telling us is that
well you know if you're if you're white
you get all this privilege you should
turn that down
why should i why should i turn it down
see
the problem is that the left
they've gotten rid of any objective
notion of morality
so they have no they have no language
for morality anymore so they can't even
really explain
why i shouldn't take that deal you could
say well it's wrong
it says who says it's wrong you say it's
wrong by your standard
that's not my standard i don't care
about your standard
well but it hurts people why should i
care about that well you should
so who says who see
they've gotten rid of by getting rid of
morality
they they get rid of morality and then
they tell you if you're white that you
should sacrifice all of these wonderful
perks that you allegedly get why the
hell should i sacrifice it now you know
what
until you can explain to me on a moral
basis you want to bring objective
morality back into this deal here
and you want to bring that back into
your world view and we can we can live
in a culture that that that is
that rests on objective morality then
fine so that's a deal i'll make
that's my deal bring objective morality
back in
and then i will sacrifice all of these
supposed perks that i get which will be
easy because i don't have them in the
first place so
i'll hand them over they don't exist
i'll hand over the empty bag with my
white perks
and um and that's the deal i'll make
that deal that deal right there
but if you're but if if if we're gonna
if you're gonna keep
objective morality out of the bargain
then hell no
i'll take it all sounds great
give me more give me more give me more
privilege for my whiteness i love it
why shouldn't i
number two a tweet from the u.s army
official account
um and you know probably in the army
they're reading this exact same book i
would think
uh here's the tweet from them a couple
days ago it says extremism can tear
apart cohesive teams
colonel timothy holman is the army's
chief
diversity officer and his aim is clear
do what he can to help open a path for
future army leaders and make the force
as diverse as the nation it defends
so we have diversity now this is of
course not a new phenomenon
at least not new in the last couple
years but um we have diversity officers
in the army now and they they want
the the force to be as diverse as the
nation defense
why why should the why do you want the
force to be as diverse as the nation at
defense
if you were you know if you're a a
a famous celebrity you know and you you
needed bodyguards
around you when you leave the house and
you needed you needed guards at your
actual home
are you going to worry about them do you
are going to worry about them being
diverse
or do you just want the most effective
people who are going to do the best job
of keeping you safe
regardless of what they look like
why should diverse why should diversity
matter anywhere
why should it matter especially in the
military which prior to going insane
was all about uniformity being
an army of one they used to say i don't
even know if they have that slogan
anymore
if they do it that's still gonna have to
get rid of it because you can't be an
army of one if diversity is the most
important thing
we want everyone to be in an individual
and express themselves that was never
the deal that was never the point
you want people to move and be as one
unit
which requires uniformity which doesn't
mean that everyone has to have the same
skin color but it does mean that
diversity cannot be your primary guiding
principle
we're going to get to a point and i
think we're there already where
um conservatives are going to stop
sending their kids
into the military or rather going to
stop
stop encouraging and start discouraging
their kids
from going into the military i mean that
that's going to happen
it's already happening
you know as much as i as much as it kind
of pains me to say it if my
you know my son is not anywhere near old
enough yet but if he was if my son was
18 years old right now today
and uh he would when i get home tonight
if he were to come up to me and say hey
dad you know i'm thinking i want to join
the military
i would try to talk him out of it i
would try to talk him out i wouldn't be
able to stop him he's 18 he could do
what he wants but
i would definitely try to talk him out
of it
because you're going to go into the
military and be subjected to this be
subjected to left-wing
brainwashing that you can't escape from
that you that you don't have the right
to even object to in any public way
i mean it's bad enough if it happens at
work um but at least there you have the
option you can speak up
if you get fired you get fired you know
what you can quit you can leave
and get another job there's still a lot
of risks involved there but
with the military if they're doing
something you don't like you can't just
say i'm done i'm out of the military
it's not that simple
so i would have to think as a as a a
parent as a conservative parent i would
have to think well okay my son's gonna
be
subjected to this madness um he's not
gonna have the ability to really
speak up against it or protest it
on top of that you know we have a
president right now who's using the
military as a political prop
political pawns they've militarized the
capitals my son going to be sent
to do that or if not that he's going to
be sent to some far-off country to die
to for for the sake of spreading
democracy to people who don't want it
that's you know that's where my mind
would be going and i'd have to i'd have
to go with
no i don't i don't think you should if
you do i would
respect i think it's an honorable thing
but um
i don't think you should and i and
that's
more and more i think conservative
parents are saying that
and then what happens because i tell you
one thing the left is not going to
supply
enough manpower to the military to
protect this nation not even
not anywhere close to that
so the military with this stuff they are
actively
attacking and discouraging
the very group of people that they need
conservative parents conservative
patriotic
families that's who supplies the
military with its manpower
and right now their goal is to basically
alienate all of those people
not a smart idea
okay um let's see here where are we
sharon osbourne okay we'll play so so
from uh from cnn it has begun
we talked about this yesterday the
process to officially end sharon
osborne's career for committing the sin
of criticizing cancer culture
you know after outrage we talked about
this yesterday uh she she defended piers
morgan who got fired for criticizing
meghan markle
and was accused of being racist and and
sharon osborne spoke up during her talk
show called the talk on cbs
and she said he's not racist um and then
because of this they shut down
production they they they they're doing
an investigation
and i said yesterday she's done like
they're they're gonna they're gonna take
her out now her career is over because
of this
and now it has started here's the report
from cnn it says
the talk co-host sharon osborne is
fighting back against accusations that
she had used racist and homophobic
language
while speaking about her former
colleagues on the cbs talk show
the accusations were made tuesday in a
story written by journalist yashar ali
citing former talk host leah remini who
spoke on the record in the piece and a
number of unnamed sources
and now they're they're um
dredging up all this stuff that you
supposedly said in the past all these
racist remarks and everything
but nobody was talking about this before
nobody cared about this before uh and
now
we're gonna now right after sharon
osborne expressed an opinion that the
left doesn't like
now they're going to quote hold her
accountable for all these racist things
that she allegedly has been saying for
years
allegedly and the worst thing is that
they still
you know they still act play dumb and
say what are you talking about where's
this is this is just a story about
people reporting things that she said
over the last 20 years
yeah why now though you're doing this
now to punish her
for disagreeing with you and you know it
and that's cancelled culture
so what we're looking at after shannon
osborne loses her job which she
certainly will probably by
some point today uh maybe you know at
some point today it'll be announced if
not tomorrow that she's
she's gone uh and when she's gone that's
gonna be three talk shows three
prominent
hosts or tv hosts anyway who've lost
their job over the last couple of weeks
for criticizing cancer culture sharon
osborne chris harrison of the bachelor
and pierce morgan three of them
in like three weeks lose their jobs
four criticize and cancel culture and
yet cancel culture doesn't exist we'll
be told
remember that in an interview with
entertainment tonight um
sharon osbourne addressed these claims
that are being made well not so much the
racism claims but she
she addressed the controversy trying to
defend herself some more and uh here's
what she said
sharon said what unfolded on air felt
like a betrayal from her co-host
after a pack they made in february there
was a situation
in february carrie ann was given a
question to ask elaine
and carrie anne didn't want to ask it
but it came from the producers to ask
elaine
and it was if black people can use the
n-word
why can't white people use the n-word i
would love to hear what you have
which is a very naive question to ask
we all know why so elaine got very upset
with her response carrie anne started to
cry
so we agreed we would never be
surprise each other with questions if we
thought the other one hadn't been
prepped
and we said we will never put ourselves
in this situation again
where we set each other up so we all
agreed as women
got you back i finished saying what i'm
saying and then cheryl asked me these
questions which i didn't
know and they were written questions and
then elaine's reading her questions
stand up for anti-racism and i'm like
i've been set up don't try and cry
because if anyone should be crying it
should be me
and i went like how
dare you all do this to me
i'm your sacrificial lamb so that's her
defense
and uh not that she needs to defend
herself
what she was saying in the original
in her original comments that started
all the controversy well there's nothing
wrong with any of it so she doesn't have
to defend herself
but her defense is pretty good yeah it's
she could be lying about all that but um
sounds like a pretty credible story
and she's saying look they they sprung
this on me
and they they know that we don't do that
on this show
and that's something in general when
you're on a show together you it's even
if they didn't have a pact
originally you know you don't if you're
doing a show with someone someone's a
co-host and you know you have a
difficult question to be difficult for
them
you don't spring it on them on the air
right um and so that's what she was
upset about perfect perfectly rational
defense but here's the problem
uh it doesn't matter first of all does
there's no defense and the reaction to
this online to this
that interview with entertainment
tonight the reaction from the cancel mob
and
from the left one in the same of course
is but oh well no she's trying to make
herself the victim huh
yeah she is the victim who else is the
victim
what her co-hosts who are still gonna
have a job and are perfectly fine
they're the victim because they had to
listen to her opinion if there's any
victim here yeah i guess it's her
she'll be fine she's worth 200 million
dollars but
even so she's the one's gonna lose her
job and she's the the social pariah so
yeah she's the victim not anybody else
on that stage
but it doesn't matter because they're
not going to listen and also
you already apologized sharon osbourne
she already apologized
and gave the the she issued the
statement saying this and that and i'm
so sorry and everything
too late too late to defend yourself
why did you apologize at all if you if
you have a rational explanation which of
course you do because again you do
anything wrong to begin with
she should have come out from the very
beginning and said you know what
this is bs i didn't say anything wrong
these people sprung this on me they know
what they did
they're the bad guys here i don't care
what any of you people think they know
what they did should have said that but
uh you can't you can't do both
you can't kind of apologize tearfully
and also try to defend yourself
that doesn't work you already admitted
guilt too late
too late all right number five huge news
here for the new york dailies news um
big
big stuff huge huge headline news
there's a gay
captain america on the way the daily
news reports marvel comics is
celebrating the 80th anniversary of
captain america
with a gay teen superhero the publishing
company said in a press release that its
newest hero aaron fisher is making his
debut on june 20th
or rather june 2nd he'll be featured in
a new limited series titled the united
states of captain america
the series will feature the original
captain america steve rogers teaming up
with captain america's of the past
um including bucky barnes sam wilson and
john walker
traveling across america to find his
stolen shield and they're going to find
all these other captain americas or
rather
i think it should be captains america
find these other captains america
and uh one of them is going to be this
this gay teenager and again big
groundbreaker this news article says
it's groundbreaking
to have a gay character right no you
speaking of not having it both ways you
didn't know it's not groundbreaking
anymore to have gay characters
there's a lot of those all over the
place and so it's it is no longer
historic or groundbreaking or new or
anything it's just
totally normal it's what everyone
expects um
so they're gonna have the gay captain
america the thing is when i first saw
this
story pop up on on twitter i i really
thought it was a joke i kind of skimmed
over i didn't see that i didn't see who
wrote the headline
because they show the image of what this
gay captain america is going to look
like
and he looks like a gay captain america
that somebody would
make up to make fun of the idea of
having a gay captain america
and yet it's it's for real and the other
issue
um that i would say is when i heard
about this i thought
okay gay captain america i thought
i thought captain planet was already
sort of a gay captain america i thought
that was his role
apparently i was wrong all right let's
move on to reading the youtube comments
liam wall says
matt it says matt seems like the kind of
guy who could handle himself in a knife
fight
i like to think i can but please don't
call my bluff on that one
mama g says matt please make your own
brand of beard care products so i can
buy them for my husband's beard
his is fine but yours is great
well i i appreciate that
if you'd bring great shame and disgrace
to your husband if he knew that you were
looking at another man's beard though i
have to say
uh let's see it says another comment
says matt i don't quite get it
sure praise ellen page for being a gay
white woman but the transition without
the change in sexual preference only
makes her a straight white male
something we're supposed to criticize
not praise seriously
elliot go home you've made yourself
irrelevant yeah well this is the this
of course is the uh one of the many
contradictions that you get with
left-wing gender theory with especially
with their their theories on sexual
orientation and how those interact with
their theories on gender
uh because they say that sexual
orientation is immutable and cannot be
changed
milo yiannopoulos says that he's not a
gay man anymore and they say that's
impossible
you know once gay always gay you can
never be it's ingrained within you you
it's not a choice
well yeah but if i can change my gender
that means i can change my orientation
no way around that if you're saying that
because you you think it's that you as
someone on the left you can simply
declare
that milo yiannopoulos is still gay even
if he says he isn't
yeah but if he became a woman which
he can do um and was attracted to men
now he's straight
that his sexual orientation changed by
your logic
from gay to straight if he's really a
woman now
attracted to men then that means that he
is really a straight woman
because he's attracted to men
no way around it but of course there's
so many logical contradictions
and uh their way of navigating it is to
simply ignore it
and that's all finally dan says matt
just checking if you're going to get a
stemi
check hope to hear back um
first of all i'm not even gonna answer
that question
you know how i feel about the stimulus
welfare payments
um which are being issued for no good
reason whatsoever
but calling it a stimmy i i am not on
board with this i am not okay with it
nobody ever consulted me we all decided
to start calling the stimulus checks a
stimmy
a stimmy you're a grown man presumably
calling it a stimmy this thing
where and i think this is one of the
great one of the great crises one of the
great threats that we face as a culture
where we're grown adults even men
are shortening words by adding an e
sound to the end
so like veggie comfy
stimmy it's it is disgraceful
my children don't even speak that way
okay my oldest kids are seven they don't
even talk that way
if my kids where can i have some veggies
i would say vegetables you mean
use the whole word doesn't take a lot
more effort yeah you hear grown men
at applebee's saying yeah can i get the
steak with some veggies
can i get some veggies with the steak
please with my steaky
oh this chair is really comfy glad i
could buy all this with my stimi check
pathetic horrible
anyone who says stimi check they should
immediately have their check revoked
that's my take on that you know there's
nothing better than waking up
after the alarm goes off and you've had
a deep and restful sleep there's nothing
better than that and then nothing worse
than the realization that you have to
face another day
in this cruel and heartless world but
don't forget about that let's focus on
the sleep
helix sleep has a quiz that takes just
two minutes to complete
and matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you if you want to have the perfect
sleep you got to get a helix sleep
mattress if you like a mattress that's
really soft or firm you sleep on your
side or your back your stomach
or if you sleep really hot with with
helix there's a
specific mattress for each and
everybody's unique taste you don't need
to take their word for it helix was
awarded the number one best overall
mattress of 2019 and 2020 by gq
and wired magazine there's a reason for
that you can discover the reason
yourself just go to helixsleep.comwalsh
and take their two minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life
i it's but you gotta go it just takes a
minute
and it's so amazing that you take this
quiz a few questions and then they send
you the mattress and you think yeah this
is exactly what i was hoping for
right now helix is offering up to 200
off and free pillows with all mattress
orders for
our listeners at helix sleep dot com
slash walsh that's helix sleep.com
walsh for up to 20 off your mattress
order
and candace owens um she's she's here
her show has finally started
uh and you know we know she's no
stranger to controversy has absolutely
no fear when it comes to speaking her
mind
we saw this just yesterday as she
renewed her fight with cardi b
over cardi's i guess we'll call it a
performance at the grammys
needless to say candace lives rent-free
in a lot of people's minds and you just
never know
which one of her opinions will go viral
which is why you should tune in to her
new
talk show candace starting this friday
march 19th the show will be exclusive to
daily wire members so you've got to be a
daily
remember first to be a part of this and
to see what everyone's going to be
talking about
and you can get a new membership uh for
25 off with code candace over at
dailywire.com
subscribe so again don't forget go to
dailywire.com
subscribe use code candace for 25 off to
get access to candace's new talk show
that's dailywire.com subscribe use code
candace for 25
off now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
so today on st patrick's day it falls to
me as a man of irish ancestry to speak
up on behalf
of my people i'm afraid i must inform
you
that if you are not irish
then you are not permitted to take part
in today's festivities if you're wearing
green you must remove the offending
articles of clothing at once
do not drink green beer do not wear a
four-leaf clover pin do not make any
references to leprechauns or other
mythical irish creatures do not eat
corned beef and cabbage
certainly don't eat lucky charms just in
general because lucky charms taste like
little chunks of packaging styrofoam
coated in sweet and low but also because
it's offensive
my culture is not a breakfast cereal the
fact is that to do any of the things
that i just listed is to appropriate
my irish identity and culture it is to
degrade and cheapen
the lived experience of the irish and to
trivialize
the historical marginalization and
persecution we have suffered
and to fetishize fetishize
our identity by attempting to celebrate
alongside us you will be committing an
act of unfathomable unspeakable bigotry
now you may point out that non-irish
people who celebrate st patrick's day
are obviously appreciating irish culture
not stealing it in fact
when i warned about the dangers of irish
appropriation on twitter last night the
embassy of ireland yes the actual
embassy of ireland
responded from their official account
taking my tweet entirely seriously which
is great because it was serious of
course
and declared that anyone is welcome to
celebrate saint patrick's day it's
appreciation not appropriation they said
but this is a case of internalized irish
phobia i'm afraid to say
i mean surely we all know that the
appreciation not appropriation line
wouldn't fly in any other context
if the irish embassy defended white
people who wear dreads on the basis that
its appreciation not appropriation
they would be condemned as racist we all
know that and so i am condemning the
irish
embassy as racist against themselves
which you really hate to see now you
might also argue that st patrick's day
isn't solely an irish holiday after all
st
patrick himself wasn't even irish he was
kidnapped by irish pirates
and forced to live in ireland as a slave
i mean he was himself appropriated you
might say
also many of the traditions associated
with st patrick's day have developed
over
time and not just in ireland you could
argue that st patrick's day as we know
it
is more american than it is irish at
this point you could argue all of that
but the problem is that white people who
wear dreads
are accused of appropriating from black
people even though black people didn't
invent dreads and weren't the first ones
to wear them
kendall jenner was accused of
appropriating tequila from mexicans
when she started her own tequila bread
even though native mexicans didn't
invent tequila
this is a common theme among
appropriation claims the people who are
allegedly being appropriated from
are not the unique originators of the
appropriated thing
yet it's still appropriation in those
cases somehow just as it is
in this case now most of all in
objecting to my claim that st patrick's
day is being appropriated
you might insist that the whole concept
simply makes no sense whatsoever a
holiday isn't a car or a bicycle or 50
in your wallet it can't be stolen styles
can't be stolen cuisine can't be stolen
to use a popular phrase these are social
constructs
another person's participation in such a
construct does not hinder your ability
to participate in it you are not
deprived in any way
nobody's peeing in your pint of guinness
just by celebrating the holiday
unless they're literally peeing in your
pint of guinness which would be a whole
new issue to deal with
anyway you may you might say all of this
about st patrick's day and you might
even be right
but sadly none of those excuses work
when it comes to non-white cultures so i
will have to insist that it doesn't work
here
and the fact is clear if you celebrate
st patrick's day today
you are directly victimizing me
the trauma that i feel from your saint
patrick's day celebration
is hard to put into words maybe because
it doesn't exist or maybe
because it's so indescribably painful
as a person of irish descent a pid we
call ourselves which when added to the
acronym for black and indigenous people
of color becomes
p-i-d-b-i-p-o-c lgbt
as such a person when i see pictures of
on social media of non-irish individuals
eating lucky charms or drinking green
beer
i mean i i can't express
the pain in a way that that fully
captures the totality
of my emotional experience
now do i think that you should have your
life ruined for celebrating st patrick's
day
do i think that you should be labeled a
bigot and cast out of society for yes
i do it's the only way the only way
but remember even as i advocate for
completely disproportionate penalties
against you for doing something totally
innocuous and innocent
the real victim is me please consider my
feelings in all of this
it doesn't matter if my feelings are
unreasonable you should be required to
accommodate them anyway
after all i'm the irish one here well
part irish a certain percentage never
mind that i'm claiming victimhood based
on my membership in a group
but never mind the question of whether i
really belong to that group in any
meaningful way
those are racist questions is racist ask
that of meghan markle
just as it's racist to ask it of me it
is racist to defy me or question me at
all as i am the victim
do as i say that's the best way that you
could celebrate st patrick's day if you
must
by bowing before me and submitting
yourself utterly to my every whim
maybe if you do that maybe i can finally
find peace and healing and that's what
really should be
most important to you so in conclusion
needless to say
anybody who is not irish and celebrate
st patrick's day today is cancelled
and should be thrown immediately into
the sea and drowned
happy st patrick's day we'll leave it
there for today
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky
the show is edited by danny d'amico our
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters
the matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
20 21. today on the ben shapiro show
cardi b
slanders candace owens family and
candace absolutely destroys her
america's racial politics get even more
contentious and president biden's border
crisis explodes that's today on the
bench bureau shall give it a listen